Amanda ballet on this team Calloway CBS
sports golf reporter and she's failed
horribly in this the last couple of
times here haven't you Amanda no I'm
pretty sure I picked the winner no you
did no you didn't know you picked Marc
Leishman every single time and you know
what all right so what's the draft order
here Paulie okay
seaton Amanda Todd Dan me McLovin okay
all right so fire away sheet no Connor
well the last time I said he wasn't
gonna finish even in the top ten and
I've been horribly wrong so far about
Brooks koepka I'm gonna take him right
off oh wow that's a shocker okay you're
getting it finally you're giving him the
respect a man deserves that's I like
that Jamaal Inari's give me my first
pick he's gonna defend his title friend
jazz go Mon Ami
okay all right who's next I am going to
go with mr. Rory McElroy a lot of
pressure there lot of pressure
by the way Amanda Tiger Woods said he
reached out to Brooks koepka about
playing a practice round and Brooks did
not get back to him he says you know for
whatever reason well I think we figured
out the reason it's because Tiger didn't
want to play with Kefka he wanted to
pick Rikki Elliott kept his caddy brain
to get Elliott has played this golf
course over a thousand times in his
estimation so I think Kefka kind of
treating Rikki as a secret weapon this
week so I think he's ghosting everybody
I like that I like that okay who's next
I am so let's see I've seen a ton and
it's me I'm gonna go Xander softly yeah
he's due he's gonna win it he's gonna
win me a major all right Paulie you're
next
Tiger Woods mmm-hmm McLovin back to back
jack okay I'm gonna go jordan Spieth and
Dustin Johnson all right that's nice
nice little combo platter there
polyester
Thomas Fleetwood
oh that fairway Jesus is not caught on
according to Amanda so it's just Tommy
Fleetwood
I like Tommy flea what do I do
John Rama Lama ding dong or Justin Rose
I got to surprise pics but I'm gonna
maybe John I'm going John ROM
begrudgingly he'll be combustible on
Sunday
let's see toddler I am going to go Ricky
Fowler
yeah you like Rickie Fowler all right
Amanda I am going to go you know what
let's just pull the trigger we all know
it's gonna happen
my man mark me seat no counter
back-to-back back-to-back
I'm gonna go henrik stenson henrik von
Stenson I like that pick a lot and I'm
gonna go man Justin it's Justin Rose
still on the board Justin Rose is still
on the board is Adam Scott still on the
board Adam Scott us to a meeting Adam
Scott Adams Scott a man whose looks are
better than his swing and his swing is
beautiful okay I stole mine we go
Patrick can't lay okay
Patrick can't lean all right and then
toddler I am going to go with Justin
Rose since he's still up there named
Justin Rose nice little pic I'm going
off the board here
I'm going Matt Wallace mm-hmm
he's a professional golfer yes he is I
mean he's not just like a fan who's won
a contest I'm going Matt Wallace he
golf's for a living he's 50 to 1 your
next poll
sorry--but shocked yeah yeah I better go
Jimmy Lipper on you Justin Thomas please
okay okay
back-to-back McLovin I don't think this
guy's but no one picked couch right no
one no one picked couch no they did not
okay I'm gonna go with my Dark Horse
Shane Lowry okay and by the way I have
no idea who Shane Lowry as you could
walk in right now but someone told me
he's good I think he once led a major
after 54 holes that's all I know
Paul you're next what would you say
Amanda he's a WGC champion he knows how
to win on a big stage mm-hmm bowling man
ray Cindy Shambo still available he is
he's in man and Matt Wallace is gone
right he's not available anymore mad
double check he's on my big board
Wallace if Matt Wallace shows up on the
the first page of the final leaderboard
Paulie you have to do a shower [ __ ] I'll
go with Louie Oosthuizen Oh Louis Jason
might have the prettiest swing on tour
now it's me um I'm gonna go
Matthew Fitzpatrick you tanking is it
you're gonna kill next
I'm drinking okay yeah I've got some I
got four Guinness in to me already
toddlers I'm gone with the skinny
fasting lefty Phil Mickelson man drop
some pounds some elby's they're int Todd
Amanda great ball striker yeah I know
okay Kevin Kisner all right
seaton it's up to you where's home okay
well I used to take this guy all the
time and he never did anything for me
but eventually one day it's gonna happen
for Thomas Peters Tomas Peters okay and
that's it
there's a few big names that are still
left on the board they're the kind of
golfer who has to win here is what
Amanda or who yeah I think this is we're
all ready for this week because we've
been seeing like 20 under par when the
bombers taking advantage this is not a
bombers course so it's going to be
accuracy way over length Darren Clarke
talks about it earlier in the week that
you can miss the fairway by a couple of
beep anything past that and you're
pretty much dead in the water so I think
you got to look for a guy that isn't
necessarily long off the teams and
straight scrambling is gonna be key and
obviously the putters always a big deal
but yeah that's the kind of guy you're
not going to overpower this golf course
I any means
should we take notice of what Brooks
koepka said that he doesn't practice and
the other tournaments is he kidding or
as is Brooks just being honest you have
to love that he gets up for what's
important for him and he executes
beautifully when when he's a hundred
percent committed you know but I think I
think we all kind of feel that way once
in a while in our jobs right he just he
just happens to say it and be honest
about it on the big stages which you
know take it or leave it but Brooks
koepka is nothing if not I think himself
every time he every time you speak yeah
I think so too
hey Amanda's safe travels great to talk
to you again yeah thank you guys that's
Amanda Bally own esteem Callaway and CBS
sports golf reporter for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]